So, there are few different types of logos.
You can have an icon that's representative of the product or company name...
...like Red Cross or Apple.
Or you can have an icon that's purely symbolic and abstract...
...like the Nike swoosh or the Twitter bird thingy.
You can have a purely typographic logo which might just be written out in a typeface...
...like Charity: Water or Google.
Or the letter forms might become the unique logo itself like eBay or Subway.
And then sometimes you'll have clever logos with hidden symbols or messages,...
...like the arrow in FedEx or the arrow going from A to Z in Amazon.
So, before you even think about starting to design your own logo,...
...think about what really makes a logo successful.